Hello Kitty fire offer 55 with the  address of the emergency  systems how about  yes but the closest Street on the corner  is  I don't know it wasn't success I usually  you don't know isn't that uh  is that correct  no  yeah  is there someone else there with you  right now  he's fine okay can you hand him the  phone because I can hear him a little  bit better than I can hear you hi hello  okay sir listen paramax already on the  way so that they need to get in there  uh no there's a security gate on the  neighborhood but he'll just let him  through okay okay just want to make sure  I have the right location I have no idea  where they're at right now so over I  think they're here okay are they there  with you okay  all right thank you